well it looks like the true sons are
getting bolder under their new leader
general anderson he used to be a
strategist for ridgeway and it looks
like his ambition has reached new
heights he's smart they're keeping him
at a secure location we're getting
reports of five of his true sons moving
on dc
major castillo a civilian turned true
son
castillo's background is in engineering
he's been taking over radio frequencies
and broadcasting these rants that
frankly if you didn't know better could
be quite the recruiting tool
sergeant daniels this woman is a piece
of work or getting reports of her
indiscriminately assassinating civilians
in the street
she's on a rampage
we've also got a logistical nightmare on
our hands with lieutenant chang
his background and experience has shored
up the true sun supply lines and weapons
we can't afford to let him build their
stockpiles
then there's major xander she has some
anger management issues xander's been
torturing and interrogating civilians i
don't know what she's hoping to learn
from them but we can't allow her to
carry out this inquisition
and last but not least is captain lewis
we haven't actually seen him in dc yet
but we've intercepted comms that imply
he and general anderson are planning
something big
agent you know what to do
[Music]
malcolm castillo was the senior engineer
at the pentko fairview nuclear power
plant
expecting his first child with his wife
sharon the prospect of the future was
both exciting and daunting
he'd always been very particular about
how things should be done and when it
came to preparing the house for the
arrival of their new baby this was of no
exception
castillo had a plan and this would be
one of the major contributions he could
actually do for his expectant wife and
he was eager to get started as soon as
possible
so for the sake of their marriage and to
avoid any more unnecessary stress sharon
had decided that at five months pregnant
it would be a good time to visit her
family in new york
this would also be one of the last times
she would be completely child free and a
black friday shopping spree with her
sister in manhattan sounded perfect
the plan was simple she was to spend two
weeks bonding with her sister while
castillo focused on getting the house
ready
unbeknownst to her and the multitude of
shoppers on black friday a deadly virus
known as the green poison had been
released
and sadly while out shopping sharon two
contracted the virus
assuming that it was no more than just
the flu she refused to seek treatment
her main concern was that the doctors
might prescribe her something that could
harm her unborn baby
ten days later
at a clinic in brooklyn
sharon died
utterly broken and grieving the loss of
his wife and unborn child
castillo immersed himself deeply into
his work in the hopes of keeping his
mind busy
eventually he moved himself into the
facility to ensure that the plant
remained functional at all times
as the pandemic continued to progress
the national guard was ultimately sent
in to protect the compound and in order
for castillo to remain on site he would
have to enlist
even after completing basic training his
primary objective still remained the
same
as the on-site expert he was to continue
in his role of keeping the power plants
safe and operational
however always there and in the back of
his mind he believed that sarah the jtf
the government and in turn the division
were all heavily responsible for what
happened to his family
he held the belief that there was no way
possible that they were unaware of
amherst's plans
and that they simply just allowed it to
happen
anderson who was a logistics officer to
the leader of the true sons antoine
ridgway was successfully able to tap
into castillo's grief along with further
heightening his mistrust of the
government
by using castillo's anguish and genuine
experiences to express his deepest
heartbreak anderson was able to convince
the national guard to abandon their post
and thus allowing the true sons to take
control of the plant
nice to meet you castillo
i've heard great things wish i could say
the same dusk excuse me i don't care if
your watch is red your division and now
you're working with the black tusk i can
assure you
i'm a true son then why are you still
wearing that garbage the best way i can
support the true sons is to take
advantage of the existing infrastructure
i thought that was something we had in
common you're smart so are you
and we are specialists in our fields
as long as you are loyal to ridgeway
to the cause
i promise to keep you safe you really
are a true son i am
now give me the tour
i've never been to a power plant before
do i need to wear like a lead-lined suit
or something
only if you go near the reactor or your
radiation meter goes into the red
but
that won't happen
lynette edwards codenamed dusk was a
third generation marine
shortly after her first tour she was
recruited by the shd
after the outbreak dusk was activated in
washington dc but it didn't take long
for her to come to the conclusion that
the institution was corrupt in fact she
was finding herself more and more
aligned with the true son's way of
thinking
eventually she decided that enough was
enough she turned rogue and joined up
with the true sons
when the true sons leader antoine
ridgeway was eventually hunted down and
killed by the division dusk went on to
continue ridgeway's work with a group of
true sons who were devoted to his cause
unfortunately the attacks had left them
weakened and short on supplies
she would do whatever it took to help
her new family
dusk would use her contacts to gain a
connection within the black tusk and
offer a trade in return for food water
and weapons
barton schaefer would get in contact
she explained the situation that her and
the true sons were in supplies were
critically low and that they didn't have
enough weapons to go around
baden agreed to the request of
assistance and made a deal where they
could work together
with all of this happening castillo
would keep on working tirelessly to keep
the power plant operational while also
continuing to obsess over the events
that led to his wife's death
castillo we've been having rolling
blackouts everything stable with the
grid nothing is stable with the grid
everything is old and failing that's
comforting should i be looking for a
fallout shelter everything is stable
with the reactor the reactor and the
grid are two separate things
trust me if the reactor failed you'd
know oh
well you're the expert your local power
supply has nothing to do with our work
here if you're having rolling blackouts
brownouts or unstable power you're gonna
need to send someone down to the relay
stations and transformers and see if
they need maintenance i'll see if i've
got anyone who knows that
infrastructure good luck
start with ex-public works employees
or i guess raid the secretary of the
interior's office for a map of the power
stations you're funny i'm serious go to
city hall they should have schematics
for all of this stuff
it should also be online your precious
isaac should have all that data
you should be an agent i'm happy being
an engineer i don't need to play sheriff
it's probably squatters someone taps
into the line doesn't know what they're
doing and [ __ ] up the whole system
you'll need to check the stations then
you need to send the exterminators to
take care of the rats chewing on the
wires
should be like riding a bike for you
agent
after some time had passed and the
leader of the true sons antoine ridgeway
was killed by the division and then dusk
during the barton schaefer manhunt
general anderson would step up and take
the reins
anderson had ambitious goals for the
true sons and plan on expanding their
reach far beyond washington dc
it was around this time that castillo
had decided that it was time for him to
put down his work and investigate
further
he wanted to go into dc to find out more
and who was responsible
but without him on site there would be
no one to run the power plant
so anderson made a deal with him to
train up true sons members to work in
his place while he was gone
how are the new recruits doing great
we've got four shifts 10 people per
shift
40 skilled prisoners trained and ready
to operate the reactor in case anything
happens to me
each shift has a true sun at the helm to
keep them in line and train any future
replacements and each of them has two
backups
we're set for the worst case scenario
and the best case best case if we want
to expand our operations we have the
opportunity to build a mobile team to
take control over another reactor
the infrastructure design and basic
mechanics are similar enough that my
crew should be able to figure out how to
keep the lights on that's excellent news
castillo thank you sir
about that favor you've more than earned
it
transpose on their way you will have a
squadron at your disposal
good luck in dc
i hope you find what you're looking for
thank you sir
after training enough true sons to run
the plant general anderson rewarded his
dedication by sending him to washington
dc to investigate sarah and the
division's role in his wife's death
but anderson had ulterior motives behind
this gift
having already used castillo's speaking
talents to gain control of the power
plant without bloodshed previously
he saw a powerful propaganda machine
that could be placed in the middle of dc
there he could continue to bolster the
true sun's ranks or at the very least
provide a much needed distraction
it was a win either way in anderson's
his poison on the eyes
other than some idiot with access made a
choice
and the choice they made was to let my
wife sharon castillo and her sister
carolyn owens and my daughter
but we were waiting with meat to name
my child who i will never be able to
name because i will never be able to
meet her because she was still inside of
sheriff those monsters dumped their
bodies into a mass grave in central park
and set it on fire to contain the virus
after taking back a number of strategic
points of interest castillo and a group
of true sons would eventually be tracked
down and confronted by division agents
at the dcd headquarters
there he would face off against the
division agents
eventually being brought down
and killed
michelle daniels
her great-grandfather was a proud
confederate soldier her grandfather an
army man
her father an army man
and her brother an army man
a proud and male dominated family with
deep roots entrenched in patriarchy and
service to their country
the loss of her mother during daniel's
birth meant that she never truly had a
maternal figure to help advise and guide
her while growing up
maybe the softness of a mother could
have shaped her differently made her
gentle and possibly even meant a
different path in her life
yet irregardless she grew up tough she
had a hardness about her that even the
boys lacked
she was gritty careless and at times
indifferent and cold
taking her life was easy there were
never any regrets and why should there
be it was her right
she was an apex hunter
others noted with alarm her seemingly
dismissive nature in regards to taking a
life
when she fished when she hunted and that
sharpening her rifle skills was more
important than anything else
yet her father always insisted that
daniel's demeanor was just the result of
not having a mother growing up around a
multitude of males and adopting a tomboy
attitude in order to survive
contradictory to her father's efforts
and stopping the rumors daniels never
felt she needed to justify herself
her attitude had always served her well
in the past and this proved successful
in the army as well and she took immense
pleasure in testing and pushing the
boundaries of new recruits to see if she
could break them
unsurprisingly her actions were noticed
by her superiors and as a result she was
repeatedly written up for objectionable
behavior unbecoming of an officer
after serving in one tour she returned
back to her life and hometown as
civilian
there she began to work for her father
in his tackle shop and hosting guided
fishing tours on the potomac river
unsatisfied and discontented with this
lifestyle a year after leaving the army
she enlisted with the national guard in
the hopes of finding some excitement and
to stave off further boredom while also
continuing to work as a river guide
with the outbreak of the deadly virus
the national guard was activated in
washington dc and she like so many
others would eventually be merged into
the jtf
anything and everything necessary to
save what remained daniels was undaunted
by the task and ready to get to work
but eventually she became aware of
antoine ridgway
his ideals and his loyal men the true
sons
this was the moment she'd been training
for
finally a leader who wasn't afraid to do
what was necessary
someone she could admire
who would appreciate her strengths and
recognize her indifferences towards
others and death to be assets
rather than liabilities
not long after agent dusk defected from
the division she met daniels
and they would become strong allies and
friends
after antoine ridgeway's death when the
true sons were demoralized broken and
severely short on supplies and weapons
dusk make contact with schaefer to
negotiate the terms of him providing the
true sons with support
nervous about going to meet him alone
dusk reached out to daniels for backup
desk to sergeant daniels come in daniels
this is daniel's what can i do for you
dusk you free tomorrow not really what
do you need i've got to meet with
schaefer he didn't show for the last one
something feels off
could really use someone i trust to have
my back oh i thought you wanted alone
time with your boyfriend gross
gross
i don't know what fey is thinking
working with him i don't know if i can
trust this guy ah he's black tusk but
he's a boy scout we talking about the
same schaefer do you want that backup or
not better safe than sorry
i can't make it but i can lend you a
couple of guards thanks daniels
i owe you one
more like 20.
in order to get the food and the
equipment for a true sons to survive and
rebuild dusk would have to join schaefer
on an operation he would soon be
carrying out in dc
dusk and her guard of true sons were to
run point in the southeastern districts
of the city capturing multiple sites of
interest in east mall south west and
capitol hill but ultimately this was a
suicide mission
merely a distraction
dusk and her accompanying true sons
would one by one be hunted down by the
division and eliminated
and eventually even schaefer would end
up being captured on coney island
daniels took the loss of a friend very
hard and demanded revenge so she
approached general anderson for orders
on how to proceed
general anderson status report division
took dusk off the board that's too bad
we need to counter strike
uh negative daniels
but she was one of ours she was a true
son she was a rogue agent first she was
one of us but she was also one of them
and with loyalties as fluid as dusks
there's no way to know if she was
playing her own angle no no no i sent my
men with her and in time we will avenge
them but not today
we need to see how this plays out
shafer's to blame general
we don't know that for sure
but i will look into it personally we
can't keep
they're a liability you may be right
there are too many rogues in their
organization
who knows what they're really planning
and with ellis in their pocket
proceed with caution
general anderson simply brushed this off
as an acceptable loss
to him dusk was a turncoat and would
have more than likely done the same
thing to the true sons when it suited
her yet he did agree that working with
the black tusk was potentially the wrong
direction going forward
after the death of feylau at camp white
oak sergeant daniels was sent by captain
lewis to washington dc as part of his
specialised team
there she seemed to be looking for
something as reports indicated a
multitude of civilian interrogations
acted out by her personally
but it would seem she wasn't getting the
outcome she needed
general anderson yes sergeant daniels
how can i help you captain lewis said i
should talk to you
i want permission to use
advanced interrogation techniques
sergeant i know that if i can push them
a little harder i can get them to tell
us what they know about the i don't need
my permission to do what you feel is
necessary i trust your judgment thank
you sir if your methods produce results
that's all that matters oh i'll get the
answers we're looking for thank you for
being so thorough a true son leaves no
stone unturned
we'll root out these snakes
anderson was happy to oblige especially
if it would get the results that the
true sons needed
however these are the actions that would
put daniels on the division's radar
agents would catch up to sergeant
daniels in downtown west where she and
her true sons had set up a stronghold
capturing strategic points throughout
the district
one by one they were taken down and at
the bank headquarters division agents
and daniels met face to face
although she was well defended and her
troop of true sons fought hard the
agents were able to persevere and fight
through
and eventually take her down
mackenzie chang is a third generation
chinese american who was born and raised
in washington dc
his father and his mother's father were
both in the navy and so like them chang
too wanted to follow in their footsteps
enlisting at 18 he soon discovered that
it wasn't the right fit for him
he hated the water and found the navy
and their rules were not to his liking
he ended up being placed in the ground
transportation team and there he felt
his time and skills were being wasted
eventually things came to a head when he
got himself involved in a bar fight and
as a result he broke his arm and three
ribs
with a year still left on his contract
his family were able to pull some
strings and fortunately for him they
were able to get him an honorable
discharge from the navy
he returned to civilian life and got a
job as a museum security guard within
the local mall
yet he soon realized that being a
security guard at the museum was not as
exciting as he thought it would be and
began to miss regular combat trials
he endeavoured to get some of that
adrenaline rush back
so he tried his hand at airsoft and
hunting
yet these two also lacked the lustre he
was after
finally he joined the national guard in
hopes that this would bring some of the
action he was longing for
when the national guard was eventually
called on to secure the mall against
peaceful protesters chang saw this as an
opportunity to use his previous
knowledge and expertise as a mall
security guard to set up the perfect
perimeter
general anderson was impressed by the
initiative chang showed and immediately
took him under his wing and logistics
not long after the death of antoine
ridgeway anderson gave chang his own
unit
however he denied him the promotion that
chang so desired in becoming captain
until he could prove himself as a worthy
leader
chang is unwavering in his determination
to demonstrate that he is deserving of
the leadership role and ready for the
title of captain and the admiration of
general anderson
general anderson i just wanted to send
my condolences about dusk and her team
thank you shafer moving forward is there
someone else you'd like me to work with
that won't be necessary
the division has control of your supply
routes in dc how do you think you'll
survive without our assistance well
lieutenant chang has more than enough
experience organizing transpo and supply
drops we no longer require your services
as a glorified errand boy i think you're
making a mistake i've only made two
mistakes in my life the first was
trusting lao the second was letting her
bring you into our operation good night
schaefer
after agent dusk's death schaefer would
get in contact with general anderson
with everything that had gone down they
were no longer willing to work with the
black tusk
rogue agents hunters that seemed unable
to be controlled
and a leadership who were working under
their own hidden agenda
anderson decided that it was no longer
in the true sun's best interest to be
working alongside them
anything they had gained from working
with them was more than being made up
for by the work lieutenant chang was
doing in logistics
baden schaefer would leave a message
with natalia sokolova to update her of
the situation
natalya shaffer just got off the horn
with general anderson he's decided black
tusk supplies and assistance are no
longer required
the true sons are on their own and any
tentative piece we may have brokered has
been severed by the death of lynette
dusk edwards
i'm not comfortable working with the
hunters
this arrangement is creating more
problems and we are losing allies
this is not why i joined the black tusk
schaefer voices his concerns
he explains that agent dusk's death
seemed to be a large part of this
partnership breaking down
but that the hunters are his biggest
problem
they can't be trusted
they're jeopardizing the mission
this is not what he signed up for
schaefer would eventually be contacted
by lieutenant chang
shafer this is chang come in good to
hear from you lieutenant you changed
your mind about working together no so
this is a social call dusk was a good
woman and a damn fine soldier
i know she was going to meet you and you
got her killed you know that was beyond
my control you weren't even there
you left her to die
you're right i wasn't there
we've run into some complications what
kind of complications there was another
player on the field what the hell are
you talking about those division agents
weren't the only ones targeting her you
make it sound like she was being stalked
or hunted
chang just wanted to give shafer a piece
of his mind
wanting him to answer for what he did to
dusk
schaefer agreed that he'd let her down
but that there were unexpected
developments
that someone who had been brought in to
help
instead
hunted her down
after feylau's death captain lewis sent
chang into washington dc as part of a
specialized team
his job was to re-establish the true
sun's transportation and supply chain in
the area
however after capturing a number of
important locations in the foggy bottom
district he would quickly appear on the
shd's radar
after battling through chang's countless
number of truson soldiers they would
eventually catch up to him in the
potomac events center
with the division agents superior
training it wasn't long before
lieutenant chang liked so many before
him
was eliminated
amanda zander only wanted one thing in
life the opportunity to become a police
officer
it's all that she'd ever really dreamed
of the desire to uphold the law and an
eagerness to bring justice and order to
the people
she possessed a high level of dedication
and skill in her work in the narcotics
sector and nothing felt better to her
than identifying a potential target and
hunting them down
yet police work wasn't all that she
thought it would crack up to be as most
of the time it was a waiting game filled
with endless paperwork and copious
amounts of cream-filled donuts
she knew she had to find other means of
entertainment to make up for a
lackluster career so she joined a
competitive shooting league
yet zander was still not content with
her situation
she could be a dangerous person at the
best of times and especially when she
was bored
she knew it her family knew it and
recently due to the use of excessive
force on a perpetrator now her superiors
knew it too
unsurprisingly as a result she was
sanctioned
she was annoyed at herself and she knew
she had to get back on track and channel
her impulsiveness into something else
there was still so much glory out there
for her to grasp and she knew that
alarming her superior so early on in her
career was not the way she was going to
get it
in order to help her direct her energy
into something more constructive her
commanding officer recommended that she
sign up for the national guard
the hope was that the intense training
schedule strict rules and very little
downtime would help curve her impulsive
and trigger finger nature
however a month later the devastating
green poison was delivered onto the
unsuspecting shoppers of new york city
on black friday
and from then on everything for xander
would change
she along with a number of other
personnel were placed on active duty
with the jtf and it was here that a man
by the name of antoine ridgway would
become her commanding officer
here in this environment xander's
psychopathic traits of antisocial
behavior lack of empathy disregard for
others and narcissism thrived
her callousness was praised her
impulsivity was considered charming and
a notable lack of guilt was an asset
xander had finally found a place in the
world working for the future leader of
the true sons
during the events of the barden-shaffer
manhunt xander like many other true sons
blamed schaefer for the loss of dusk
if i ever see you again i will [ __ ]
kill you schaefer
that's a promise i understand why you're
angry but we need to put a pin in this
and focus on our common enemy agent lau
i [ __ ] hate that chick i don't trust
her she's been on my list for a while
not lao she's not the enemy she turned
you into her [ __ ] boy you should hate
her she has her reasons
this channel's not secure but you should
really talk to lao [ __ ] that i'm not
letting her get into my head
schaefer has been discussing what's
happening behind the scenes with faye
for a while now and he appears to be on
board
he now seems to be trying to reach out
to others to help in this fight against
the true enemy
though xander's stubbornness will
require a different approach
[Music]
what do you want douglas
just a friendly chat this about your
girlfriend
who
is that what this is about
you hate lao because you think we're
together no
i hate lao because that [ __ ] got half
of my squad killed in new york when the
reservists were called up to maintain
the quarantine oh
well
good
i'd hate to think you were so pissed
about how things ended with us doesn't
help that you're sleeping with a traitor
okay
she's not a traitor she's a good woman
she's been through a lot we all have
just give her a chance meet with her and
you'll see we can help each other
there's something bigger happening uh
you two getting married would it matter
if we were damn okay douglas you need me
to go rescue your pappy from the white
house you're gonna finally reconcile so
he can walk you down the aisle is that
the secret mission
xander focus we need to work together if
we're going to stop what's coming okay
fine
set it up
i'll meet with lao
bridget douglas aka viper would later be
a part of feylau's team in the following
manhunt
viper was the only child of charles
douglas the co-founder of the douglas
and harding military equipment company
though they weren't particularly close
and after the outbreak charles now
resides in the white house
acting as the range officer
viper was an unactivated shd agent who
instead ended up joining the black tusk
where she would later meet agent lau
xander and viper having previously been
in a relationship opened up
communications between faye schaefer and
the true sons where they appear to be
recruiting for a future operation
as a side note i really must bring up
the relationship between fae and viper
although this isn't of any particular
significance towards the story other
than linking all these characters
together it's more that i've been
getting a hard time at home from my wife
because she absolutely called it way
back when the fellow manhunt was going
on but i uh i didn't agree or include in
the video i need to remember the wife is
always right
so uh yeah my bad
regardless this recruiting attempt would
end up being unsuccessful xander would
inform general anderson who would then
get in contact with natalia circle over
but as we now know faye is out there
working under her own agenda so natalia
has no idea what he's talking about
natalia
i thought we had an understanding i
understand you no longer wish to work
with us and our fragile truce is broken
i do wish you would reconsider my kind
offer and i wish you would reconsider
trying to recruit my men to whatever
clandestine [ __ ] you and lau are
cooking up i don't have any idea what
you're talking about oh don't play dumb
it's not convincing on you if lao is
reaching out to your true sons it is not
on my orders that's on her own volition
or maybe it's your true sons that are
reaching out to her my troops are loyal
who did she allegedly reach out to major
sander oh
well this is probably a personal matter
more than professional have you seen the
state of the world no one has time for
personal matters well women like amanda
find a way to make the time
you don't have to worry no one is trying
to take her from you
she frankly would not be a good fit for
the black tusk even if she wasn't trying
to cast herself as the victim of a love
triangle just stay away from my troops
certainly general have a good day
and don't hesitate to call again if you
need anything
good luck managing xander
douglas says she can be a bit unstable
a little while later after barden
schaefer was captured by the division
and feylau was killed at camp white oak
major xander was sent into washington dc
with a team of true sons
however after reports of her harsh
treatment of local civilians started
flooding in the division was sent out to
put a stop to her plans
on the eastern side of dc they would
catch up with xander in the judiciary
square district
after taking out a number of outposts
being held by the true sons agents would
find her hunkered down in the district
union arena and while they would have
loved to be able to find out what xander
was searching for there was no chance
that she would allow herself to be taken
alive
so piece by piece her true son soldiers
would be taken apart
and in her final stand she too would be
quickly taken down by the agents
frederick lewis spent many a summer on
the ocean rescuing inexperienced
tourists who'd got themselves into
trouble of the north carolina
coastline's unforgiving seas
with the help of his father's small
fishing boat and the fact that he had
spent the majority of his life on the
ocean lewis was the perfect man for the
job
he had always seen himself as a savior
and the best person to bring back those
missing at sea to their loved ones
so unsurprisingly at the completion of
high school he joined the coast guard
and over the course of time worked his
way up into the prestigious search and
rescue team
eventually lewis married and at the
request of his new wife they moved to a
homestead in kentucky
with the property value of the old
fishing shack ballooning they were able
to buy a large estate which consisted of
40 acres
yet soon after lewis grew tired of
playing the part of a farmer and decided
to join the national guard in the hopes
of once again finding his true purpose
though after all of his sacrifices for
his wife's happiness and moving away
from the sea he loved so much and
attempting to live a less thrilling life
for the betterment of their relationship
she was the one who started looking
elsewhere
the young man they hired to help around
the farm was the perfect candidate and
two years after their big move to
kentucky she had an affair
when lewis discovered the relationship
he was devastated
after everything he'd given up he still
wasn't enough for her
so he quietly packed up his bags
collected his faithful dog got into his
truck
and left
lewis knew there was only one place he
truly felt whole
the ocean his father in the sea welcomed
him back with love and open arms
once there he rejoined the coast guard
and tried to rebuild his shattered soul
yet his efforts would soon be undermined
again
as not long after his return to north
carolina the green poison was released
sent to dc to help support the jtf the
impact of his experiences including his
failed marriage led him to be cold nasty
and unmerciful to those who was
entrusted to lead and protect
captain lewis
we ready for homecoming just a few
things to take care of here and i'll be
on my way
advanced team is already on location
lieutenant chang's delivered and we have
more than enough supplies for the party
that's great news when major castillo
got to dc he recorded some very
emotional reports
we decided to make some of them public
no greater recruiting tool than a
civilian who found purpose with the true
sons careful captain you keep delivering
work this good
i might think you're after my job
not to worry general i hate the office
politics working with the team that's
where i belong
making sure the trains run smoothly and
we all come back safe
that's where i know i can be of service
leadership support roles and
infrastructure
that's the work that fuels me
we need people like you captain that's
the thing about the division a bunch of
lone wolves with no real infrastructure
and alliances they were set up to fail
hire a bunch of specialists train them
to use another to solve their problems
this is what you get
you can't depend on someone and build
trust if you only talk to them when you
need something people like that are
willing to acknowledge their
shortcomings or ask for help until
they're already in trouble this is why i
knew following you and ridgway was the
right call he was proactive he was
willing to make the tough calls because
he saw where the road was heading
and now that he's gone we will finish
the journey together and bring our cause
to every state in the nation
good luck in dc
captain lewis checks in with general
anderson to give him an update on how
his team has been going in dc
everything is running according to plan
and he's ready to enact his part of the
operation
but one thing is for certain
neither of them hold the division in
particularly high regards
referring to them as a failed initiative
flawed from its inception
status report
we are getting ready to take the network
but there have been some unexpected
roadblocks
increased instability in the power grid
surges and blackouts some data anomalies
insecure calms and increased brute force
attacks
some of my men are reporting that they
have seen some odd lights and feel like
they are being watched
i thought the stress is getting to them
but the reports are coming from all
times a day and from folks i trust
major zander is looking into it but i
don't know that our methods will yield
the results we're looking for
once in dc unusual reports start
flooding in
xander was set forth in order to find
out what's going on but lewis doesn't
expect her direct approach will provide
the results they need
however this doesn't matter for now the
target they've been hunting for has been
found
captain lewis and his men set course and
head there
immediately lewis what's your eta
should be arriving at the party by
sundown tomorrow negative i need you
there now we've got a location there's
movement
looks like they are getting ready for an
extraction we need to head them off the
pass
permission to take main roads and make a
loud entrance permission granted
this will put us on the division's radar
it was inevitable maybe this time
they'll actually see what we've been up
against i hope you're right frankly if
they haven't figured out what's going on
by now i don't think they ever will
lone wolves they have no trust and no
support network you pull one pin and the
entire communication chain breaks down
this is why we have contingencies
send me the coordinates i'll get my team
there asap
the division caught up with captain
lewis at the jefferson trade center
but before the agents could enter lewis
puts out a message over the comms
this
this is kelso put down your weapons and
surrender the division will take care of
the black tusk it's not the black tusk
you should be worried about have your
team meet me inside
i don't trust this guy
don't shoot him
i want to know what he's up to
lewis is the last member left of his
team and he warns that it isn't the
black task that are the problem that
there is something worse within these
walls
someone he refers to as the recruiter
finally
what's your status
armed and ready but the lone survivor of
my team if you want us to help you we
need you to secure the shade node you
don't trust me to have your back
i don't trust you to have my friend
that trust has to be earned
captain defend the node we can take care
of black tusk watch out for the
recruiter or what oh you'll see
trust has to be earned
well kelso doesn't trust him for now the
agents and lewis will be teaming up
against this new threat
network detected
what the [ __ ] i lost you for a second i
thought maybe the captain took out the
nodes or something
detected
enemy comes revealed that jack bonnie is
the one leading this operation
and that this is some sort of test for
him
you ready
yes tell barney to stop checking up on
me i know what i'm doing you know this
is a test right it's his test not mine
i'm not looking for a promotion that's
why i'm checking up on me
the agents catch up with lewis outside
of the shd node where he has secured the
area stopping the black tusk from once
again taking down the shd network
agent kelso the true sons have secured
the entrance to the shade node your
columns are secure
thank you captain
no problem agent
true sons know how to follow orders
i'm set up
agents on approach
sir get ready to be impressed
agent i've got you covered captain what
are you doing the rest of the facility
is secure i'm providing air support we
can't let bonnie get away what do you
mean air support hey agent unless you
need a powder shower might want to be
glass
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
agent i don't want you breathing that
[ __ ]
friendly fire my ass
malfunctioning
you're not the only one with air support
systems
after fighting through the hordes of
black tusk troops the agents would
eventually meet up with bonnie in the
final courtyard
although he had brought along a
marauder-class quadcopter the agents
would slowly take it down
and with the unwanted help of captain
lewis dc 62 airstrikes bonnie 2 would be
eliminated
[Music]
identification confirm agent jack bonnie
status classified
deceased
he was an agent
classified
bring me his watch
i've never seen that status before
what the [ __ ] is going on here captain
you know nothing kelso
so
not friends
if you finally figured out what the hell
we're really up against you know where
to find me
knock it off with the yellow powder or
next time i'll have to kill you myself
talk to your boy you're gonna need our
help my boy who the [ __ ] is my boy
this has just been a slightly edited
compilation of the season 9 manhunt
i had a lot of positive feedback about
the last one i released with people
stating they prefer my longer style
videos
but the true detail that has come from
the season was through fei laos
insurance policy comms
i've released three videos on this so
far and these will be in the description
after such a long break this season has
been an awesome step forward for the
story now that the next two seasons and
year five has been confirmed i'm really
looking forward to this new direction
they're taking the story
of course we also have the new additions
to the story that people are feeding
through to me from the yet to be
released resurgence and heartland which
sounds like it'll really flesh out the
detail in between
it looks like i'm going to be quite busy
over the next year or so i mean i
haven't even caught up with this season
yet there is so much more i'd like to
cover
anyway thank you very much for watching
i hope you've enjoyed this recap and
i'll catch in the next one for those of
you who've used this to fall asleep
you're welcome
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh